today I'm going to share the five kinds
of channels that I watch daily on
YouTube hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and not too
long ago I made a video showing the
websites that I check out every day in
my business to start my day and I got a
question from one of my youtube viewers
love you guys
David Jong who wrote in this a great
video post I love a youtube channel list
happy face this is a great question and
over the past year I've gotten more and
more and more into YouTube and there are
five main kinds of channels that I look
at every single day number one is
entrepreneurial channels and there's
really only one channel that I watch
religiously every episode that comes out
I have to watch and that's gary
vaynerchuk's channel if you don't know
Gary he's a social media expert a
business building expert he's written a
couple books like Jab Jab Jab right hook
crush it the Thank You economy he is
brash he's in your face he's opinionated
he's not afraid to let loose you know
what he's thinking and if you are
interested at all in building an online
business he is one of the best resources
that I feel are out there to learn from
out of all of the entrepreneurial
channels he's the only one that I watch
religiously right I'll watch every
single episode that comes out and is
always a nugget that you can pull so if
you haven't checked out Gary B's channel
and you should do so number two are
YouTube channels and these are channels
that I use to learn how to get better on
YouTube how to improve what I'm doing
with my videos and how to have a bigger
impact with the videos that I'm creating
there are two channels that I subscribe
to and again religiously watch every
single video that comes out the first is
video creators and that's by a friend of
mine named Tim Schmoyer he puts out
content a couple times a week and it's
sharing advice news tips he takes
questions from readers he will go out
and interview people and there's just a
lot of great information and Tim is also
a down-to-earth
genuine guy and I connect with him
easily because he wants to make the
world a better place you know he wants
youtubers that help
spread their message out there and so
again every single video that comes out
by Tim I'm watching it and usually
commenting on it
the other is Derral Eve's and Derral is
like Tammy's got a lot of advice on how
to build his channel and how you can
build your channel and get more views
and have a bigger impact
he doesn't post as frequently as Tim
does and it's easy to see on top of this
stuff it's easy to digest information
sharing it's easy kind of step by step
here's what to do again Daryl someone
that's easy to connect with his message
and what he's saying and I just like
having the variety so Tim has his views
Darryl has his views and you're getting
you know two sides of the coin and more
strategies on how to help build your
YouTube channel so if building a YouTube
channel and growing it is on your list
of things to do definitely check out
video creators and Derral Eve's number
three are learning channels and these
are channels that I want to learn from
right there
it's gonna help me in something I'm
doing in my business or my videos or one
of my companies and I'm studying
something I'm not necessarily said in
the topic but I'm studying something in
how they're creating their videos so the
first one for me in this category is TED
Talks and there are a lot of great TED
talks but there's a lot even more
not-so-great TED Talks
and my main goal with the TED talks is
to become a better speaker right these
are supposed to be some of the best
speakers in the world on display sharing
their thoughts and they have a challenge
in that it's a really tight commitment
where you can only speak for X number of
minutes there's a lot of content that
goes up on Ted and if you are watching
those every day all the way through
you're gonna basically spending a lot of
time in front of the computer watching
Ted's Channel and quite frankly a lot of
the topics aren't really of interest to
me and a lot of the speakers aren't very
good sorry to say and what I'm looking
for is how can I be a better speaker by
modeling success right it's part of what
I do is model success so can I learn
from some of these speakers so often
what I do is I'll play a video and I'll
listen to the first 30 seconds and if
the speaker has hooked me and I'm
interested in their topic then I'll stay
for as long as I want to stay until I
get bored and then I'll bounce and
usually I
rarely make it through most of the
videos and most of the time I'll bounce
in the first 10 seconds because the
speaker's already lost me so if you
can't keep me for the first 10 to 30
seconds I'm out you know hopefully gonna
learn from the guys who are keeping me
there for long the second one in this
category is casein a stat I hope I
pronounce up properly I'm putting you to
KC's Channel he was featured on gary
vaynerchuk's channel so i subscribed to
him he does a lot of vlogging and I
really loved the way that he does his
vlogs and I've done a few vlogs and
travel videos and I'm just learning his
style the different camera angles he's
using you know when he's running he'll
show himself going for a run and what he
does is he puts his phone down and then
runs back and then just to record him
doing this running scene and then he'll
run back and pick up his phone just to
get that 5 seconds of footage and so
it's I'm learning from his style it's
interesting to see how he lives his life
it's not that it's super interesting for
me to want to you know be like him but
I'm learning from his techniques of how
he's shooting his vlogs my fourth
category our friends these are people
who are friends of mine the posts in the
YouTube and I'm a huge believer that you
need to support your friends and I
watched their videos religiously I leave
comments on all of their videos and I
just like being a supporter so the first
one here is Richard you're gonna love
and he has inspirational channel that
has a lot of interviews I've been
featured on the channel a couple times
and he posts videos a lot now about fear
how to break out of your fear and
strategies to use and in interviewing
inspiring people
the second is much which is run by
Jennifer Price another friend of mine
she's a copywriter she posts videos
about her journey of writing her book as
well as effective strategies on how to
be a good copywriter if you're writing a
website or a brochure or any marketing
materials the things you need to think
about in your headline your call to
action the text so if you want to
improve your copywriting abilities and
sell more with your words use a good
channel to check out and the third
friend likely have a shout out to is
xoxo cooks this is a channel run by a
friend of mine named Adrian it's a
cooking channel I rarely cook I am NOT
good at it I don't enjoy it but Adrian I
started watching just to support her and
give her feedback and give it a like
you know add that little extra boost but
now I genuinely look forward to her
videos because they're funny they're
educational I'll often watch them with
my wife and it's a good channel to check
out it and the fifth category are
personal videos these are just things
that I like to watch for fun and
channels that I really enjoy the content
they're putting out the first one here
is Jamie gaming kurios and he makes
videos about League of Legends it's a
game that I enjoy playing in my spare
time and I like learning how to get
better and just the informative
information that he shares they're
informative information can you say that
I guess information should be
informative right
a lot of great information about League
of Legends and how to get better so I
enjoyed that channel the second is
you'll assist McClaren and he has a
salsa channel so turn patterns new moves
that you can learn always you know as a
salsa dancer you are never tapped out of
moves you can always learn more moves
and so he has a great channel that he
posed to regularly with new moves that
he's come up with that I like to try out
and then there's app to spy on which
it's a silly Channel shows a bunch of
people doing funny things might be
stupid animal tricks or fails and they
have a regular video series that comes
out and it's a good channel to watch to
unwind at the end of the day my wife and
I will often I I actually never really
watch it on my own it's more watching it
with Nina to watch her reaction to it
because watching her laugh at something
makes it funny for me where otherwise I
wouldn't normally watch Phil videos but
anyway those are the channels that I
watched in a personal category so those
are the five kinds of videos that I
enjoy watching I'd love to hear from you
in the comments what your favorite
channels are and maybe I'll learn
something new one gains some new
channels to subscribe so if you have a
favorite channel the channel that you
watch every day your your religious
every new video that comes out you have
to see what they're putting out leave it
in the comments below I'm really curious
to see what you're gonna write there and
if you like this video you want to see
more don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and the newsletter thank you for
watching another tech Tuesday video and
continue to believe I needed to hop back
on for one more second because the
the way that YouTube's watch later
function works is broken and super
inefficient and I was so frustrated with
it that staying on top of my favorite
channels and making sure I didn't miss a
video from someone like a Gary
Vaynerchuk would would upset me so much
and so I devised a hack for how to make
sure you stay on top easily of all your
favorite channels and if you guys are
just in the learning more if you're
frustrated with the watch later function
let me know I maybe I'll make a separate
video cheers guys